The crews behind the TV-show The Walking Dead
are some of the biggest fans of horror and
Sci-Fi films out there.
Not to mention, most of them have worked on
iconic horror films that have been released
over the last 30 years.
Lead by makeup special effects guru, Greg
Nicotero, they have created props and makeups
for over 100 Hollywood films.
Throughout the show Nicotero has hidden numerous
Easter Eggs referencing his favorite horror
films and more.
Remember to like our video to let us know,
if we reveal any Easter Eggs from films that
you love.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Awesome
Easter Eggs Hidden In The Walking Dead.
Swamp Thing
Wes Craven’s 1982 film Swamp Thing is based
off a comic book created by Len Wein and Bernie
Wrightson.
Executive producer, Greg Nicotero is a fan
of Wrightson’s and wanted to pay tribute
to him ever since season one but never found
the opportunity.
In season six he got his chance when Daryl
is attacked by a zombie.
Nicotero did the makeup himself on this one
so he could base the design off DC’s Swamp
Thing.
He’s not the prettiest zombie but he is
cool!
Death Star Library
Academy award winning special effects genius
Joe Viskocil has worked on such films as Independence
Day, Terminator 2: Judgement Day and even
alongside Nicotero in Leatherface: Texas Chainsaw
Massacre III.
He is also responsible for the explosion of
the Death Star in Star Wars – A New Hope.
After his death Nicotero wanted to pay tribute
to his friend and made a library called Viskocil
Public Library.
It’s a sweet sentiment from a show with
a lot of death, we just wished it exploded
like the Death Star for fun.
The Show’s Titles
As each season passes the walkers become more
and more decayed, showing the audience that
time has passed.
Another way the show does this is with the
opening title card for the show.
Each season the title becomes a little more
decayed, with added blood and grunge.
It’s a nice reminder of how the world has
gone to hell and there seems to be no turning
back.
If the show runs for another twenty years,
there may be no letters left.
X- Files Cigarettes
In season five as Daryl and Carol go searching
for Beth in Atlanta, they stumble upon an
abandoned building.
While they go through the building looking
for supplies they find a carton of cigarettes
with a familiar brand name.
The carton is named after the fictional brand
of cigarettes "Morley," that The Smoking Man
from the sci-fi series The X-Files smoked.
Are the worlds of X-Files and The Waking Dead
one or is this just homage to the 1990’s
show?
Save the Turtles
Laugh out loud moments are not what The Walking
Dead is known for.
We may get a chuckle here and there but that
is about it, when it comes to comedy.
So when Eastman is training Morgan with a
staff, it is surprising to see that Eastman
wore a t-shirt that said, “Save Terrapins.”
Then right above those words is a picture
of the turtle animal.
This is only funny because two episodes earlier
Enid had eaten a turtle as a snack.
Dare we say, this joke could leave a bad taste
in audience’s mouths?
General Custer’s Last Flight
General Custer is famous for his last stand
at the Battle of Little Bighorn, where he
lost his life fighting against Native Americans.
In the first episode of The Walking Dead,
Rick woke up in a hospital to a zombie-apocalyptic
world.
When he walked out of the hospital he found
a military helicopter with the insignia of
the 7th Cavalry on it.
This is referencing Custer’s 7th Cavalry
that was slaughtered with him on that memorable
day.
An Easter Egg reminder that history repeats
itself.
“Creepshow” Crate
With the premiere of season five, the survivors
have to escape from Terminus to survive.
As they fight their way out they pass by a
crate that has the writing, "Ship to Horlicks
University via Julia Carpenter" on it.
This is a reference to Steven King’s short
novel that was made into a segment for Creepshow.
Since executive producer Greg Nicotero owns
one of the three original crate props made
for Creepshow, he added this reference.
Luckily his cast never opened the crate!
Biblical Verses
When we first see Father Gabriel being saved
on a rock we are surprised to find out he’s
a man of the cloth.
Not to mention, how clean his collar looks.
When Rick makes his way into Father Gabriel’s
church we see a list of scriptures on the
wall.
Romans 6:4, Ezekiel 37:7 and more; what these
all have in common is they all reference life
after death or eluding death.
Very appropriate for a world that has the
dead coming back to life.
Ben Gardner from Jaws
The Governor was one of those characters that
you love to hate, but there is no denying
that there was something wrong with him.
Not only did he keep his zombie daughter around,
he also kept the fish tanks filled with zombie
heads.
So how did Ben Gardner from Jaws arrive there?
Last time we saw his head it was on the bottom
of the ocean after failing to kill the infamous
shark.
The crew states it was just another prop of
one of their favorite films.
Aged Johnny Depp
Here’s another head for you.
The Hilltop group and Rick’s team needed
to find a head that looked like Gregory to
trick the Saviours and infiltrate their base.
They lined up a group of heads on the floor
and as they look them over we see one that
is made up to look like an older Johnny Depp.
Greg Nicotero had a cast of Depp from a previous
film and decided to use it again.
Ironically the head that was used is from
a cast of Nicotero’s head; maybe he’s
hoping he looks like Depp.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any of your favorite Easter
eggs from The Walking Dead?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Thanks for watching!